وقع عدد من القوه المدنيه ومجلس السياده
في السودان اتفاقا سياسيا ايطابيا يؤسس
لمرحله الانتقاليه مدتها 24 شهرا ومص
الاتفاق على ان المرحله الانتقاليه تبدا
من تاريخ تعيين رئيس الوزراء وتنتهي
باجراء انتخابات شامله وقد رفض القوه
المدنيه السودانيه اخرى للاتفاق واكدت انه
ادى الى انشقاقات داخليه ولم يحظى بتوافق
بقيه القوى السياسيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء كان ذاك خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاش ثلاثه مسارات ما هي
ابرز معالم خريطه الطريق في الاتفاق
الموقعه بين مجلس السياده واقوى المدنيه
سياسيه في السودان
[موسيقى]
وما هي تحديات التي تواجه الاتفاق في ضوء
اعلان قوى المدنيه اخرى رفضها الاتفاق
لانه لم يحظى بتوافق بقيه القوى السياسيه
[موسيقى]
وكيف سينعكس هذا الاتفاق على ما يعاني منه
السودانيون لاسيما الازمه الاقتصاديه التي
تعيشها البلاد
[موسيقى]
باتفاق ايطاليه من اجل النظر الى حين في
بعض القضايا التي وصفت بالجوهريه
من تصريحات متفائله التمكين لحكم
مدنيات لعلى اهمها توسيع دائره التوافق
حول ما تم التوصل اليه في ظل مواقفه
معارضه ترفض الاتفاق بشده وتعتبر سببا في
شق صفوف الرافدين للحكم العسكري من بين
النقاط المهمه التي ينص عليها الاتفاق دمج
قوات الدعم السريع في القوات المسلحه
الانقلابات العسكريه وكل تغيير سياسيه
خارج الاطر الدستوريه
وقد رفض قوى مدنيه سودانيه اخرى الاتفاق
واكدت انه ادى الى انشقاقات داخليه ولم
يحظى بتوافق بقيه القوى السياسيه
والزم الاتفاق السلطات الانتقاليه بتحقيق
العداله الانتقاليه وكشف الجرائم ومحاسبه
مرتكبها كما نص على تقويم وتقييم اتفاق
جوبا للسلام مع اعتباره جزءا من الوثيقه
الدستوري
ممثل القوه المدنيه المشاركه قال ان
الاتفاق يهدف الى توحيد السودانيين تحت
رؤيه مشروع اقامه سلطه مدنيه
استكمال الانتقال الديمقراطي وتحقيق اهداف
الثوره
عنوانه استعاده الحكم المدني الديمقراطي
واكمال مهام ثوره ديسمبر المجيده وغايته
توحيد بنات وابناء شعبنا تحت ظل مشروع
وطني غائم على الحريه والسلام والعداله
والمواطنه في اقامه سلطه مدنيه ديمقراطيه
تستكمل مهام الانتقال ومقاصد الثوره
رئيس مجلس السياده سوداني عبد الفتاح
البرهان قال ان الاتفاق يعني توافقا على
قضايا وطنيه لابد من وضع حلول لها بمشاركه
واسعه من القوه السياسيه
لا تعني اتفاق مع طرف واحد او ما جهه
محدده
وانما هو توافق
وتراضي على قضايا وطنيه يجب ان يتم وضع
الحلول لها بمشاركه واسعه من القوه
المدنيه
واصحاب المصلحه بنيه الوصول لمخرجات تنهي
حاله الصراع والتشاكس القائم بين القوه
المدنيه
والقوه العسكريه حتى نمهد الطريق نحو
التحول الديمقراطي الحقيقي
نائب رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني محمد
حمدان حميدتي اكد من جانبه ان بناء الدوله
الديمقراطيه ليتطلب الاعتراف والاعتذار عن
اخطاء الدوله تجاه الشعب السوداني وتحقيق
العداله الانتقاليه لرد المظالم وفقا
تعبير
اولا
الاحترام والاعتذار منا جميعا
عن امى الدوله تجاه المجتمعات عبر مختلف
الحكم التاريخيه
[تصفيق]
هذا الاوف ادي الفرس البناء الوطني وتحقيق
السلام والتنميه والوحده والاستفاده من
التنوع وهنا لابد من التاكيد على اهميه
اقرار عمليات العداله والعداله الانتقاليه
الممثل الاممي في السودان قال ان الاتفاق
او توقيع الاتفاق السياسي الايطاليه بين
القوه المدنيه ومجلس السياده جاء ثمره
جهود الاطراف السودانيه لايجاد حل للازمه
واعاده النظام الدستوري
ان هذا الاتفاق
الاتاريا
ولكنه يوفر اساسا جيدا وجيدا جدا للبنت في
زياده الحكم المدني
العمليه السياسيه والمشاركه
في سائل التحقيق
في الاثناء شهدت مناطق في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم خروج احتجاجات دعت
اليها ما تعرف بالجان المقاومه افضل
للاتفاق السياسي الموقعه بين قوى المدنيه
ومجلس السياده
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من الخرطوم كل
من الفريق اول فتح الرحمن محي الدين
القديره العسكريه وقائد سلاح البحريه
السودانيه الاسبق
وايضا الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اشرف عبد
العزيز ابدا معك سيد فتح الرحمن ما الذي
يقدمه هذا الاتفاق ما الذي يقدمه المكون
العسكري في هذا الاتفاق غير ما قدمه في
السابق وواجه عراقي
تحيه لك والتحيه للساده المتابعه قناه
الجزيره انا اعتقد انه يعني ما يقدم
المكان العسكري هو التاكيد على انه يرغب
في حكم المدني كامل في خلال الفتره
الانتقاليه وهي يرغب في الخروج من المشهد
السياسي تماما وهو زاهد في السلطه هذه اهم
الدلالات هذه التوقيع اليوم لكن
الان الامر يعود الى المكونات المدنيه
السياسيه التي يجب عليها ان تتوافق حول
هذا
الاتفاق السياسي الايطالي لكي تتوسع قاعده
المشاركه ولكي
يجب القبول بحد يمكن ان يحقق الاستغراق
ان المكون العسكري زاهد في السلطه ولا
يريد الاستمرار في العمل السياسي ااا هذا
الامر ليس جديدا وتحديدا هو ما سالتك
بشانه يعني الان ما هو الجديد الذي يقدم
في هذا الاتفاق غير ما قدم في السابق ولم
ينفذ
هو اصلا يعني للاسف يا سيدي كان هنالك
شيكوك في ان المكونين العسكري لا يرغب في
الخروج من السلطه والمكون العسكري متشبس
بالحكم في بلاد هذا التوقيع بشهاده
المجتمع الدولي وكل المتابعين لسان
السوداني يؤكد ان المكاين العسكري الان
يجزم بانه يرغب في حكم المدني كامل ويرغب
في ان يخرج من المسجد السياسي لكن يجب على
القوى السياسيه ان تتوافق في ما بينها
الان انا اعتقد انه عندما هذا الاتفاق
الراي الذي حوله مركزيه الحريه والتغيير
هي دائما خطابه اخصائي ولم يتغير هذا
الخطاب منذ العام الماضي
لا تتطلب تغيير هذا الخطاب
المكونات التي ترغب في التفاوض الكره الان
اذا في ملعب في ملعب القوى المدنيه كان
نفهم من السيد اشرف عبد العزيز هل للقوى
المدنيه ان همم تقتنص الفرصه اذا صح
التعبير
وتتفق على رئيس وزراء كما ينص الاتفاق على
تسيير مرحله انتقاليه كما ينص الاتفاق
الايطاري
الغول مدنيه هي ظلت الراغبه على الدوام
للوصول للاتفاق والتفاهمات وغالبا مكانا
العسكريون في هذه الفتره الانتقاليه هم
اللي يؤديون الفتن والصراعات وحتى يعني
كان الامر وصل لدرجه ان يتم تحريض بعد
العناصر التي اغرب اليهم ثم قفل الميناء
الرئيسي حتى ذلك الحكومه الانتقاليه
وعندما ايضا وجدوا ان ذلك فاشله قاموا
وصلوا بمرحلها حتى ينقضوا على السلطه
المدنيه بالانقلاب ولكن الان بعد مرور عام
على الانقلاب بالتاكيد تراجع عندما احسوا
بالفشل الذريع والمقاطعه دوليه الواسعه
وبالتالي لم يكون امامهم ونصف غير التراجع
مره اخرى والقبول بالحل السياسي
السلمي لحل الازمه السياسيه الحاليه
السودانيه التي صنعنها ليست في ملعب القوه
المدنيه
الكره لا زالت في ملعب العسكريين لماذا
لانه هنالك قضايا المتعلقه به شخصيه وهي
القضايا التي سيتم استبعادها ويرجعها حتى
الان للمناقشه استكمالا لهذا الاتفاق
الايطالي بالنسبه
لعلق بالعداله الانتقاليه نعم قضايا
العداله الانتقاليه الغداء المعلقه
بالحصانات الاجرائيه الغداء المتعلقه
بتفكيك نظام الثلاثي المليونيو والمثال
المتعلقه بتعديل اتفاقيه السلام
فقط نقطه محدده اشاره اليها كل النقاط
التي ذكرتها موجوده في هذا في هذا الاتفاق
وجاري الاتفاق بشانها اين هي يعني النقاط
التي تخشى منها القوه المدنيه في هذا
الاتفاق
السؤال مين يا عم لك انت
من هذه
النقاط الاربعه النقاط الاربعه هي حددتها
هذه القضايا التي لم يستقبل الناس
المتعلقه بالعداله الانتقاليه وكما تعلم
هذه المطالب الابرز للشارع السوداني الذي
ما زال الان هو لا يؤيد الاتفاق بشكل كبير
لان لديه راي في هذه النقاب لانه يرى ان
هذه وسائل مرتبطه بشكل اساس دي اولياء
الدم
باولياء الدم خاصه الشهداء الذين تم قتلهم
منذ الانقلاب الذي وقع في الخامس والعشرين
قبل اكتوبر الماضي والذين يتجاوز عددهم
الان حوالي 120 شهدادا
سيد اشرف نعم والتحديات التي تواجه هذه
الاتفالات نعم في في ردود الفعل الدوليه
الخارجيه الامريكيه رحبت بتوقيع الاتفاق
الايطالي في السودان واعتبرته خطوه نحو
تشكيليه حكومه انتقاليه بقياده مدنيه واكد
بيان للوزاره ان الولايات المتحده
وشركائها يعتبرون جهود تشكيل حكومه بقياده
مدنيه في السودان عاملا اساسيا في استئناف
المساعدات الدوليه
عود اليك سيد
فتح الرحمن طيب الان
هذا الاتفاق يحتاج الى ضمانات ويحتاج الى
اليه واضحه للتنفيذ نحن مازلنا امام اتفاق
ايطالي
ما هي الضمانات الموجوده او الاليه
الواضحه لتنفيذ هذا الاتفاق
هو طبعا للاسف هذا الاتفاق الاتفاق
ابتدائي ومع مكون واحد من مكونات الفاعله
في الساحه اللي هو مركزيه الحريه والتغيير
مع بعض الاحزاب التي ارتدت ان تدخل يعني
المؤتمر الشعبي وان صار السنه فقط
الان ال- ال- الضمانه الاساسيه لكي ينجح
هذا الاتفاق القوه المدنيه عليها ان تجلس
في مائده مع بقيه المكونات السياسيه التي
ترغب في التفاوض هنالك مكونات لا ترغب في
التفاوض اصلا لا ترغب في الجلوس همم ولا
ترغب في العمليه السياسيه هنالك الذين
يتحدث عن التغيير الجزري هؤلاء يمكن ان
نستبعدهم من المشهد الان لكن بقيه الغور
التي ترغب في ان تجلس وتتوافق من اجل
الوطن يجب على الذين وقع اليوم ان يجلسوا
معهم وهذه الضمانه القويه التي تضمن
استمرار هذا الاتفاق
سيد فتح الرحمن
ولن تكن له فرص نجاح اذا لم يتغير خطاب
مركزيه الحريه والتغيير الى خطاب تراضي
يقبل بالمكونات الاخرى ويرضى بان يجلس
معها ويتوافق معها في كيف تكون الفتره
الانتقاليه واصلا يفترض كما قال السيد
الرئيس اليوم يجب ان العسكر للسكنات
والاحزاب للانتخابات اذا الفتره
الانتقاليه هي فتره كفاءات وطنيه مستقله
سؤال تتوافق عليها هذه القوه وتمضي
بالفتره الانتقاليه نعم يعني اذا عدنا
بالذاكره قليلا كان همم هناك عام من رئيس
الوزراء السابق عبد الله حمدوك لتشكيل
الحكومه سياسيه وكان همم يرفض المكون
العسكري حكومه سياسيه ويصر على حكومه
تكنوكراد الان
هل افهم منك بانه اذا لم يتم الاتفاق بين
القوه المدنيه موافقه ومعترضه اذا لم تتفق
بكليتها على الاتفاق الايطالى معنى ذلك
انه لن يكون هناك رئيس وزراء
ولم يتخلى المجلس العسكري او المكون
العسكري عن السلطه هل هذا صحيح
لا انا انا لا اقول يعني توافق كل القوه
السياسيه في الساحه ولكن على الاقل من
تتوسع قائده المشاركه يعني الذين شهدناهم
اليوم هم جزء صحيح من المشهد السياسي ولكن
هنالك مكونات فاعله واساسيه ومؤثره في
المشهد السياسي ان لم تتوافق هذه مع بقيه
همم القوه انا اعتقد انه المشهد يعني سيظل
كما هو انا اعتقد انه هذا الاتفاق سيدخل
همم التسويه الى حديث الترم ما هي عليه
الان
نعم
سيد اشرف عبد العزيز حتى وين التوافق في
ما بينهم بان تكون حكومه همم
محصصات ايضا انا لا اعتقد ان هنالك ما
يمنع بس فقط يجب ان يتوافقوا على قاعده
عريضه يعني هذا هذا تحدي كبير امام القوى
المدنيه سيد اشرف عبد العزيز هذا واحد من
التحدي يعني فضلا عن الضمانات والاليه حتى
الان
غير واضحه المعالم ايضا مساله قبول القوه
المدنيه الاخرى يعني لا يكفي هذا المكون
المدني الذي وقع الاتفاق هناك مكونات
اساسيه مدنيه يفترض ان تكون موافقه على
الاتفاق الايطالي كي ياخذ مساره نحو
التنفيذ كيف سيتعامل او ستتعامل القوه
المدنيه التي وقعت مع هذا التحدي
وبالتاكيد امام تحدي كبير لاستقطاب بقيه
القوه الرافده لهذا الاتفاق خاصه الغور
المهنيه بالتوقيع على هذا الاتفاق بمعنى
ان هنالك شروط ايضا وضعت للتوقيع على هذا
الاتفاق هنالك هو هو المجلس المركزي
للحريه والتغيير ترى ان مثلا هنالك الكتله
الديمقراطيه ولكن في هذه الكتله
الديمقراطيه التي تجمع احزاب التي تجمع
حزب المرغني الاتحاد الديمقراطي وحركه
العدل والمساواه وحركه التحرير السودان من
الاضافه الى قليل ترى ان هذه الكتله
بالضبط كانت ايده لحد كبير الانقلاب وتمهد
معه حتى النهايه وكانت تقف الى صلاه
الجانب البرهان وكانت هي جزء من ما حدث من
فوضى للانتغال في طوال الفتره الماضيه
وبالتالي ترى انه مشاركتها ينبغي ان
تستبعد وهي تلتزم فقط بمشاركه حركه تحرير
السودان من ناوي والعدل والمساواه باعتبار
ان هذه الحركات هي جزء من الاتفاق جوبا
وايضا هذه الك الديمقراطيه لديها راي وترى
ان هذه الموسيقى نفسها هي معيبه ولن توقع
عليها وهي ملتزمه بالوثيقه الدستوريه
الماضيه وانه لابد ان يتم التعامل
بالوسيقه الدستوريه الحاكم الان ولا يهتم
بهذه الوسام
وهذا هذا ما اسال عنه يعني عفوا عفوا سيد
اشرف هذا ما اسال عنه بالضبط يعني هذه
المواقف الجذريه اذا صحى تعبير الرافضه
لمضمون هذا الاتفاق من تلك القوه المدنيه
كيف سيتم اقناعها بالانضمام الى هذا
الاتفاق كيف سيتم هذا الامر باختصار ارجوك
الوساطه الوساطه الرباعيه تبذل وصادر
الرباعيه تنزل جهدا وكذلك اليه ثلاثيه في
اقناع هو الكتله الديمقراطيه خاصه على
الحركات الموقعه على سلامته باعتبار
النظيرها مصالح لان الاتفاق نصها على
مشاركه هذه الحركات في السلطه وهذا من
السهل يقنعه لانها تناظر الان من اجل
الكذب اكبر قدري من المحادثه لانها شاركت
بوزاره السابقين كانوا ليس من اهل الكفاءه
والاهليه وهي طوائع تحاول ان تمرر ذلك
وايضا هي مضغوطه لان هنالك اكثر من اربع
حركات اخرى وقعت على سلام جوبا هي الان
تشارك في هذا الاتفاق هذا من جانب هنالك
قوه اخرى وهي ذات الاهميه والتاثير هذه
القوه ممثله في لجان المقاومه وايضا في
الحزب الشيوعي السوداني وتجمع المهنيين
وتسمى بقوه الضغط
طبعا التي ذكرتها تتحدث عن حاله الضغط
تعيشها هذه القوه المدنيه ربما تساهم في
دفعها نحو الانضمام الى الاتفاق سيد فتح
الرحمن هنا ال ال المكون العسكري هل كان
ايضا مضغوطا
بالازمه الاقتصاديه التي تعيشها البلاد
بحجم المساعدات الدوليه باعتباره هو في
السلطه هل هذا الضغط الذي عاشه المكون
العسكري دفعه الى هذا الاتفاق مع القوه
المدنيه وكيف سيؤثر على الوضع الاقتصادي
هذا الاطلاق
يعني بالتاكيد يعني هنالك ضغوط اقتصاديه
كبيره جدا وللاسف يعني هذه الضغوط يتاثر
بها المواطن البسيط وليس المكونين العسكري
يعني للاسف يعني ونحن ظللنا نعاني من هذا
الظلم الدولي حتى خلال الثلاثون عاما فكره
الحكم عمر البشير ايضا كانت هنالك عقوبات
غازيه ولكن هذه العقوبات يدفع ثمنها
المواطن البسيط وليس الحاكمين وليس
المؤتمر الوطني الان ايضا العقوبات
الاقتصاديه والحساره الاقتصادي الذي فرض
على السودان يعني يعاني منه المواطن
البسيط نحن نامل ان بعد توقيع هذا الاتفاق
والتاكيد جديه المكونه العسكري فانه زاهد
في السلطه ويرغي في تحول المدني ان تتدفق
المساعدات وان
البنوك والمؤسسات الماليه التي تمول
الانتاج
والاقتصاد في الدول الناميه كلها يجب ان
تعود وت الانتاج في السودان حتى تتحرك
عجله الانتاج وحتى يتحرك الاقتصاد الان
للاسف السودان خلال هذه السنين الثلاثه
دفع فاتوره غالي جدا برفعه دعم وتطبيق
فاتوره همم
البنك همم الدولي كامله دون اي مقابل ودون
اي تحريك لعجله الانتاج يدونا تشغيل لاي
همم موارد تدعم الاقتصاد
الحقيقيه التي يمكن تكون يعني غد ارقمت كل
هذه القوه ان تزعج جاهزه
فتح الرحمن
واشكر اشرف عبد العزيز الكاتب السياسي
كنتم معنا من السودان من الخطوط شكرا لكم
مشاهدينا تنتهي من برنامج ما وراء الخبر
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]